let's run the uh the Great Clip that you
have Zach from uh buddy Carter
uh Congressman this committee including
myself who believed that the Chinese
Communist party is engaged in
psychological warfare
through Tick Tock to deliberately
influence U.S children
you know you see behind me if you look
behind me Mr crew you see some of the
challenges that we've seen on Tick Tock
you know about them you know about the
milk crate you know about the uh about
the Blackout Challenge you know about
the uh NyQuil chicken challenge the
Benadryl challenge do they have these
same things over there
do they have these kind of challenges uh
China Congressman I'm really glad you
asked this question do they yes or no
I'm not sure because come on now sure I
really am not sure the milk crate
challenge which he's talking about is
from a 2016-2017 Facebook challenge the
Blackout Challenge that is a thing that
82 children died of between the years of
1995 and 2007 or eight way before Tick
Tock the Benadryl thing Good Morning
America did an entire segment on that in
2002 because it was such a problem among
teens this is not these are not
Tick-Tock challenges and
it's just so ridiculous to say they're
doing psychological warfare it's you
know doubly stupid right because these
are not Tick-Tock challenges uh in any
meaningful way and these are the kinds
of moral panics that happen all the time
my favorite in this whole scheme of
things going back uh more you know a
couple decades was the jenkum challenge
which was uh I mean it was made up but
it was the idea that uh you know
teenagers were fermenting their own
urine and excrement and huffing it and
it you know a bunch of not surprisingly
uh police departments Sheriff
departments in Florida sent out
advisories and it's you know it's a joke
I mean it's like smoking banana strings
or something like that in order to get
high uh back in the 60s so it's it's
wrong that way but then the
psychological component this seems to be
a very Lively fear about Tick Tock
because it's being directed by the
Chinese government and you know what
they're doing is they're having our kids
you know kill themselves on milk crates
are choking each other or eating you
know everything from chicken to
Impossible Burger to whatever soaked in
Nyquil while Chinese kids on the
equivalent of tick tock and Tick Tock
does not exist in China in the same form
but they're doing you know they have
calculus challenges how much of this is
just a recurring fear uh that gets
expressed through New Media Taylor yeah
I mean it's total nonsense and it is a
complete recurring fear and I actually
wrote a big feature about this stuff for
the Atlantic years ago before Tick Tock
even launched and it's so relevant
because I used to I spent years
debunking all this stuff related to
YouTube
um and even Facebook right the Momo
challenge was uh
you know children were killing
themselves because of this WhatsApp
message
um these are all related to like playing
into parents worst fears right parents
see their kids spending new time on an
app they don't understand this new
technology some police officer says you
know oh that's actually that could kill
them I mean SNL famously did a skit God
like nine or ten years ago mocking all
of these you know fake teen moral Panic
news stories but I think in the age of
you know misinformation and all this
stuff spreading all over it's just it's
easy it's this stuff is even it's just
it's taken hold in a way that it never
has before and I think that's because
Tick Tock you can play into that China
fear right it has that extra layer of
like you know the Chinese let's play
that clip from Kathy Rogers McMorris who
I uh the congresswoman from uh
Washington State who uh maybe a decade
ago was actually seen as an incredibly
Pro technology she was part of a new
wave of Republicans who were embracing
the internet and and all that I promise
uh let's run this clip real quick Trust
American values
Tick Tock has repeatedly chosen the path
for more control more surveillance and
more manipulation
your platform should be banned
have you seen any evidence that tick
tock's algorithm is uniquely damaging as
compared to YouTube or Twitter or
Facebook and so forth no I'm mean I was
just dying in that testimony because we
have seen time and time again Facebook
Twitter you know YouTube
amplify you know horrible extremist
content through algorithmically driven
feeds and recommendation systems that
harm has been proven that has harm has
not been as proven on Tick Tock
um Tick Tock has very strict moderation
guidelines for sure
um you know just the way that Facebook
does obviously there's things that you
can't upload
um but you know
the problems that they when they're
talking about Tick Tock yes algorithmic
feeds have problems those are those are
problems across like all algorithmic
feeds that's the problem with optimizing
for engagement that comes with certain
problems those problems also appear on
Twitter Instagram and YouTube in fact as
we've seen you know those companies have
been around longer but we've seen a lot
more damaging stuff come off out of
those companies which is why they're so
eager to make Tick Tock the boogeyman
I've got a clip from Dan Crenshaw who I
uh represent from Texas who I think
summarizes is the the fears uh more
succinctly than anyone else in this
testimony so I'd just like to play his
summary here and get everyone's reaction
to that
Tick Tock is able to collect massive
amounts of personal data we all know
that that means it could if it desired
to use this data to influence narratives
and Trends create misinformation
campaigns encourage self-destructive
Behavior purposefully allow drug cartels
to communicate freely and organize human
and drug trafficking and to be fair all
social media companies could do that but
here's the difference it is only Tick
Tock that is controlled by the Chinese
Communist party all these other social
media companies are not even if it is
not happening yet it could in the future
the long-term goal of the Chinese
Communist party is the demise of the
American power and that starts with our
youth at any moment they could demand
that all of tick tock's data be used to
design an AI algorithm with the sole
purpose of promoting Chinese interests
and destroying our society from within
you want to know why that's Democrat why
that's why Democrats and Republicans
have come together on this that's why we
are so concerned
man I just hope that he brought an extra
diaper because he just himself over
the you know like I mean he's he's an AI
algorithm just like trying to compute
doomsday scenarios right let's start
first with the idea that the Chinese
Communist party is controlling Tick Tock
in America is that plausible
I I mean I'm I'm not a China expert I
think these things are good to
interrogate but there is no evidence of
that and you know I think we saw that
them correcting that type of
misinformation I I think I mean I know
that China experts you know have
opinions about this but there's just
we have we need proof right to if we're
going to be making laws and we need this
we don't we don't have the Smoking Gun
it is what it is you know if that stuff
existed it would be a completely
different conversation as you'll note it
what he says what Crenshaw says many
times could this could happen this could
happen sure it could a lot of things
could happen but we don't we we need to
we need evidence that it is happening or
some sort of proof could you talk a
little bit about how people actually use
social media or programs or platforms
like tick tock are they enslaved by it
or do they actually do a pretty good job
of regulating and moderating their use
and I mean I just think it's like any
form of entertainment do people spend
nine hours watching TV sometimes and
binging TV yes do people play video
games for 10 hours yes do people spend
too much time on social media sometimes
yes this is entertainment as Tick Tock
builds itself as an entertainment
company I don't know if it's the
government's role to come in and
regulate
you know how much time we're spending on
an entertainment platform I just that
seems dystopian I mean sometimes you
want to let loose and watch too much I
just think this is you know we need to
be able to
we take some sort of personal
responsibility here I mean we can't just
it's wild to me and the way he's talking
of you know as he mentioned sort of
flippantly all social media companies
can do that those things that he's
listed those those examples he list in
the beginning there is evidence that
Facebook has done every single one of
those things right there's evidence that
YouTube has done every single one of
those things there's not evidence that
Tick Tock has done those things that was
an excerpt from reasons live stream with
the Washington Post Taylor Lorenz if you
want to watch another excerpt from this
live stream or the whole thing go here
and here
and come back every Thursday at 1 pm
Eastern Time to Reasons YouTube channel
and watch this live and participate ask
questions and we'll we'll get answers
for you thanks for watching